calificar la medida como controvertida
es suavizar la decisión el presidente de
túnez caixa jet prolongó la suspensión
del parlamento hasta diciembre de 2022
la cual a su juicio otorgará el tiempo
al pueblo para reflexionar sobre las
reformas a la constitución y el resto
del sistema político antes de un
referendo en julio una parte de la
población acogió con satisfacción el
anuncio
exigimos un cambio en el sistema
electoral entonces no es son su decisión
es una demanda popular él no tomó estas
decisiones sólo porque el pueblo salió
el 25 de julio a exigir la abolición de
todo el sistema la disolución del
parlamento y los cambios a la ley
electoral
pero para otros genera dudas
las elecciones parlamentarias son el 17
de diciembre de 2022 están demasiado
lejos futuro
está estancado quiere tiempo para
implementar su plan mundial
para los oponentes políticos de esa jet
no hay dos formas de hacerlo dicen que
el presidente está consolidando su
control autoritario sobre la joven
democracia luego de destituir al
gobierno suspender al legislativo y
aumentar el poder del ejecutivo en julio
resumen del discurso soy el estado soy
el presidente soy el gobierno soy el
parlamento soy el poder judicial
se esperan protestas en rechazo el
viernes en el marco del undécimo
aniversario de la revolución tunecina
[Aplausos]